porque desde que rusia invadió ucrania
el pasado 24 de febrero no han parado
las acusaciones por parte de occidente y
de vladimir putin en los últimos días
rusia acusó a eeuu de supuestamente
llevar a cabo actividades militares
biológicas en ucrania los señalamientos
llevaron a moscú a convocar una reunión
extraordinaria del consejo de seguridad
de naciones unidas acusando al gobierno
de poleo y miri selenski de estar
supuestamente destruyendo pruebas de
experimentos en laboratorios con
patógenos biológicos el embajador del
kremlin ante la onu afirmó que occidente
ha desplegado 30 laboratorios para que
trabajen con una peste el ántrax o el
cólera señalando a sus oponentes de
querer desatar una crisis de salud
pública en medio de ya la crítica
realidad humanitaria de ese país tanto
el gobierno de ucrania como el de eeuu
han rechazado todas las acusaciones
rusas y también por el contrario
aseguran que es rusia es el país con un
historial del uso de este tipo de armas
y que temen que puedan ser utilizadas en
territorio ucraniano en medio de todo
este conflicto y para ello entonces
saludamos a los jose maria gili garré el
score director de international security
observatory y profesor del colaborador
del centro universitario y zen de
cartagena españa además de la facultad
de seguridad adscrita a la universidad
de murcia gracias profesor por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
le preguntó primero qué son las armas
biológicas a veces se confunden con
armas químicas cuál es la diferencia
en realidad
en ese contexto de las armas biológicas
podemos hablar de todo tipo de armamento
sucio capaz de liberar en un entorno
determinado
patógenos de diferente tipo que pueden
ser bacterias pueden ser virus pueden
ser de diferentes etiologías pero en
realidad es un arma en construcción que
en un entorno de conflicto bélico
simétrico y en este tipo de contextos
ningún ejército
tácticamente
lo pueden utilizar o lo debe utilizar
porque puede volverse muy rápidamente
contra contra el quiere decir liberar en
un suelo plano como es ucrania un ataque
bacteriológico
bien sea por parte de un actor o de otro
puede suponer que se vuelva contra tus
propias fuerzas porque una vez los
liberó al medio ambiente pues las
riendas nubes tóxicas etcétera no
sabemos qué control puede haber sobre
ellas es muy incontrolable y los
argumentos aducidos en el consejo de
seguridad extraordinario que se produjo
en acciones unidas por parte de rusia
son absolutamente paupérrima sus más
explicaciones no hay carga probatoria
diría que ni siquiera la han trabajado
esa carga probatoria como lo pudo
trabajar en su día eeuu hablando de las
famosas armas de destrucción masiva en
irak que luego no existieron profesor
entonces hablemos de la peligrosidad de
todas estas armas cuáles serían además
los posibles usos
bien en los usos pueden ser destinados
directamente a la población civil
bueno pues para producir acciones
masivas tos y infecciones masivas y
también ataques de este tipo se orientan
a las producciones agrícolas a la cabaña
animal en definitiva puede segmentar se
tipo de objetivo que se pretende atacar
con la liberación de determinados
patógenos pero insisto no hay pruebas no
hay ni una sola prueba evidente que nos
haga pensar que esas armas éstas se han
trabajado como diferencia por parte de
eeuu y ucrania tenemos experiencias de
liberación de este tipo de armamento y
demás si en contextos más asimétricos
recordemos por ejemplo la secta
terrorista que en los metros en japón en
el negro llegó a liberar sustancia como
como el gas sarín por ejemplo que no
consiguió el objetivo pero de haberlo
conseguido de haber funcionado todos los
sistemas de dispersión por aerosol es
decir por el aire habría conseguido
matar incluso a 10.000 personas en el
ataque murieron unas apenas nada más se
consiguió abortar todo es ataque
terrorista en ese escenario asimétrico
es muy preocupa en este conflicto
simétrico me inclino a pensar más en que
sería rusia la que podría utilizar bajo
ataque de falsa bandera una cuestión así
pero insisto es tácticamente los
ejércitos no son muy proclives y más con
las experiencias que tuvimos en la
primera guerra mundial en la guerra de
españa en el norte de áfrica es la
propia segunda guerra mundial en vietnam
y en determinados escenarios sabemos que
son armamentos para utilizarlo como
armamento es algo muy incontrolable
claro profesor también usted ponía sobre
la mesa el consejo de seguridad de la
onu donde rusia acusó a ucrania y
también a eeuu y cuáles son realmente
los fundamentos porque rusia hace estas
acusaciones en qué se basa y segundo
también hay quienes dicen que rusia está
haciendo eso también en funcionarios del
gobierno estadounidense en rusia está
lanzando estas acusaciones para en un
futuro después que no sabemos si se va a
producir así o no y poder usar ellos sus
armas biológicas que tiene que decir al
respecto
bien hay que atender primero hay que
tomar todas estas informaciones las que
se produzcan de un bando de otro hay que
tomarlo con la 5 en la debida precaución
estamos en un contexto bélico con dos
actores marcados y con un mundo
polarizado en torno a este conflicto por
lo tanto habrá manipulación es lo que se
llamaba antes guerra psicológica y ahora
se llama guerra de influencia no tiene
sentido hay que tener precaución a la
hora de estas aseveraciones tanto
por parte de un actor en particular
rusia lo que sí sabemos es que ha
utilizado este tipo de arma dentro es el
cloro y demás en algunos sitios en
algunos escenarios y me inclino a pensar
que tiene cierta cierta veracidad o
podemos quedarnos con la frase que
utilizó el presidente acciones y de
educar ya cuando dijo atiendan las las
advertencias o las amenazas que rusia
dice que otros países pueden ejecutar en
este contexto porque serán las serán las
las técnicas gripe russia rus ya ha se
ha desenvuelto en este contexto bélico
desde la mentira pensemos cuando a días
antes semanas antes incluso cuando los
analistas a fiesta hacíamos también una
llamada
de atención expresa respecto de la
eventual invasión como respondí a putin
hablaba a occidente a los periodistas o
los analistas de expediente nos llamaba
histéricos y finalmente se produjo la
invasión más allá incluso de lo que
podíamos prever que era la zona del
donbass donestk ones no no
css abordó una guerra total bajo la
premisa de la mentira en este sentido
hemos de tomar estas aceleraciones con
mucha precaución pero de producirse
ataques mediante armamento químico y
biológico debemos prepararnos para un
escenario desconcertante que va a ir
mucho más allá del territorio contenido
en el ataque porque una vez si liberan
determinadas toxinas determinados
elementos patógenos el medio ambiente
las consecuencias son incontrolables
insisto